we're given a bunch of lines here that
intersect in all different ways and form
triangles and what I want to do in this
video we've been given the measures of
some of the angles this angle that angle
and that angle and what we want to do in
this video is figure out what the
measure of this angle is and we're going
to call that measure X and so I
encourage you to pause the video right
now and try it yourself and then I'm
going to give you the solution so I'm
assuming you've unpause it and you V
you've solved it or you've give it at
least a good shot of it so let's try to
do it and what's fun about these is
there's multiple ways to solve these and
you kind of just have to keep figuring
out what you can figure out so let's say
you start on the left-hand side right
over here if this is 121 degrees then
you'd say well look this this angle
right over here is supplementary to this
angle right over there so this is 121
degrees 121 degrees Plus this green
angle has to that has to be equal to 180
degrees so this is going to be 180 180
minus 121 let's see that's the same
thing as 80 minus 20 180 minus 20 would
be 60 so that's going to be 59 degrees
so let me write that down
that's going to be 59 59 degrees now we
see that we have two angles of a
triangle if you have two angles of a
triangle you can figure out the third
angle because they need to add up to 180
or you could say that this angle right
over here so we'll call that question
mark we know that 59 plus 29 plus
question mark needs to be equal to 180
degrees and if we subtract the 59 the 29
from both sides we get question mark is
equal to 180 minus 59 minus 29 degrees
so that is going to be 180 minus 59
minus 29 let's see 180 minus 59 we
already know is 121 and then 121 minus
29 so if you subtract just 20 you get
101 you subtract another 9 you get 92 so
that's going to be equal to 92 degrees
this is equal to 92 degrees well if this
right here is equal to 92 degrees this
angle right here is vertical with that
so it is also going to be equal to 92
degrees and now we're getting pretty
close we can zoom in on this triangle
down here let me save some space here so
let me just say that this that over
there is also going to be 92 degrees and
at this triangle down here we have two
of the sides of the triangle we just
have to figure out the third and
actually we don't have to do much math
here because we have one side that's
sorry we have two angle we have two of
the angles of this triangle we have to
figure out the third angle so over here
we have one angle that's ninety to one
angle is 29 the other one will be 180
minus 92 minus 29 and we don't even have
to do any math here because we that's
essentially this exact same angles that
we have in this triangle right over here
we have a 92 degree angle we have a 29
degree angle and the other one is 59
degrees so in this case it has to be
also 59 degrees because over here they
added up to 180 so over here they'll
also add up to 180 so that will also get
us to 59 degrees we could just get that
by taking 180 subtracting 29 subtracting
92 and then if this is 59 degrees then
this angle is also going to be 59
degrees because they are vertical angles
so we're done X is equal to X is equal
to 59 degrees now there's multiple ways
that you could have reason to through
this problem you could have immediately
said so let me let me let me start over
actually maybe a faster way but you
wouldn't have been able to do is kind of
as basic steps there as you said look
this is a this is an exterior angle
right over here it is equal to the sum
of the remote interior angles so 121 is
going to be 29 Plus this thing right
over here and we ended up doing that
when I did it step by step before but
here we're just using kind of a few
things that we know about triangles
ahead of time to maybe skip a step or
two although I like to do it the other
way just so we don't make sure we make
sure we don't do anything anything weird
so anyway this is going to be 129 minus
29 which is going to be 92 and if this
is 92 then this is also going to be 92
and then if this is X and this is also
going to be X and you could say X plus
92 plus 29 is equal to 100
80 degrees and you would say X plus 92
plus 29 is going to be 121 degrees we
already knew that before and so that is
going to be that is going to equal 180
degrees and so X is equal to 50 59 X is
equal to 59 degrees so there's a ton of
ways the ton of ways that you could have
you could have thought about thought
about this problem